right now a big meeting is underway to
reassess mandating vaccines for all
employees within nevada's higher
education system now this has really
been a controversial topic with health
and jobs on the line victoria saha
joining us now live from the nevada
system of higher education on maryland
parkway with what could be decided
tonight victoria
denise's special meeting comes in one
day before hundreds of employees were
set to lose their job if they didn't
comply with the vaccine mandate this
meeting could vote to keep that mandate
or terminate it
earlier this month the board approved
the vaccine mandate for all college
employees in nevada they had until
december 31st to comply around 92
percent of employees are fully
vaccinated leaving more than 500 at risk
of losing their job nevada governor
steve sisolak has made it very clear he
is in support of this mandate releasing
a statement saying in part the regions
are empowered under nevada's
constitution and to end laws to take
such measures and i support their
efforts to create safer and healthier
communities for all of our students
staff and faculty this meeting comes
after state legislators struck down a
vaccine mandate for college students in
nevada last week which the governor did
not agree with
i'm disappointed obviously we're going
to continue moving forward to department
of health and probably get that
regulation back in place but there's
going to have to be a meeting in january
the regions will have three options to
decide on tonight keep the mandate as
written or pushing the effective
termination date from tomorrow to
january 15th or eliminating it if it's
eliminated notices of termination would
be rescinded and if it isn't and
employees decide to leave they have
until january 31st to go back to their
job only if they provide a proof of
vaccination victoria saha live local now